foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn about devops testing tools
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply the now without
further Ado let's get started with our
agenda for today's session
we will get understanding Jenkins and
the fundamentals of Jenkins followed by
that we will understand selenium and its
fundamentals and finally we will
understand J meter and its fundamentals
once we have a brief understanding of
these three tools and fundamentals then
we will have a practical demonstration
on all these three tools to have a
comfortable understanding of the devops
testing with that having said if you are
an aspiring devops engineer and
searching for an online training and
certification from the experts and the
best universities then search no more
simply learns postgraduate program in
devops with Caltech University in
collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details on this
program please use the link in the
description box below having said that
over to our training experts for today
on the devops testing tutorial hey there
are you exploring test automation are
you wondering why everyone is talking
about selenium around you do you want to
know what selenium is all about if yes
yes this is the video for you simply
learn brings to you a very simple
tutorial on selenium what should you
expect from this video before you start
understanding any automation tool it's
good to look back into what manual
testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
Suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the Primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a Facebook
application and in Facebook application
let's let's open the Facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first name the surname mobile number
or the new password and you will also
test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an accessibility testing you would do
a performance testing for this page or
say a response time after you say click
on the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
these test cases ready what do you do
you start executing this test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
one by one again until all the bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now if one has to run test cases
with hundreds of transactions or the
data sets and repeat them can you
imagine the amount of effort required in
that now that brings us to the first
demerit of the manual testing manual
testing is a very time consuming process
and it is very boring also it is very
highly error prone why because it is
done annually and human mistakes are
bound to happen since it's a manual
executions testers presence is is
required all the time one is to keep
doing manual Steps step by step again
all the time he also has to create
manual reports group them format them so
that we get good looking reports also
send this reports manually to all
stakeholders then collection of logs
from various machines where you have run
your test consoliding all of them
creating repositories and maintaining
them and again since it's all is a
manual process there is a high chance of
creating manual errors there scope of
manual testing is limited for example
let's say regression testing ideally you
would want to run all the test cases
which you have written but since it's a
manual process you would not have the
luxury of time to execute all of them
and hence you will pick and choose your
test cases to execute that way you are
limiting the scope of testing also
working with large amount of data
manually is Impractical which could be
the need of your application what about
performance testing you want to collect
metrics on various performance measures
as a part of your performance testing
you want to simulate multiple loads on
application under test and hence
manually performing these kind of test
is not feasible and to top it all up say
if you're working in an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers testers are building their
test and they are executing them as and
when the bills are available for testing
and this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run this test multiple
times during your development cycle and
doing this manually definitely becomes
very tedious and burning and is this the
effective way of doing it not at all so
what do we do we automate it so this
tells us why we automate one for faster
execution two to be less error prone and
three the main reason is to help
frequent execution of our test so there
are many tools available in the market
today for automation one such tool is
selenium birth of selenium much before
selenium there were various tools in the
market like say rft and qtp just to name
a few popular ones selenium was
introduced by gentleman one called Jason
Huggins way back in 2004. he was an
engineer at thoughtworks and he was
working on a web application which
needed frequent testing he realized the
inefficiency in manually testing this
web application repeatedly so what he
did was he wrote a JavaScript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and he named it as
JavaScript test run later he made this
open source and this was renamed as the
selenium core and this is how selenium
came into existence and since then
selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in Speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate No human errors since your
test cases are automated Human Resources
required to execute automated test cases
is is far less than manual testing
because of that there is a lesser
investment in human resources it saves
time and you know time is money it's
cost effective as selenium is an open
source it is available free of cost
early time to Market since you save
effort and time on manual execution your
clients will be merrier as you would be
able to ship your product pretty fast
lastly since your test cases are
automated you can rerun them any point
of time and as many times as required so
if this tool offers so many benefits we
definitely want to know more detail
about what selenium is selenium enables
us to test web applications on all kind
of browsers like Internet Explorer
Chrome Firefox Safari Edge Opera and
even the Headless browser selenium is an
open source and it is platform
independent the biggest reason why
people are preferring this tool is
because it is free of cost and the qtp
and the rft which we talked about are
chargeable selenium is is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as I said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in JavaScript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium ID which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like Java python
c-sharp Ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or Advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has supports for Windows Macs
Linux even Ubuntu as well so you can run
your selenium test on any platform of
your choice and hence selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tools for automating your web
applications selenium set of tools so
let's go a little more deeper into
selenium as I said selenium is not a
single tool it is a suite of tools so
let's look at some of the major
components or the tools in selenium and
what they have to offer so selenium has
four major components one selenium ID
it's the most simplest tool in the suite
of selenium it is integrated development
environment earlier selenium IDE was
available only as a Firefox plugin and
it offered a simple record and Playback
functionality it is a very simple to use
tool but it's mainly used for
prototyping and not used for creating
Automation in the real-time projects
because it has its own limitations like
any other record and replay too selenium
RC this is nothing but selenium remote
control it is used to write web
application test in different
programming language what it does it
basically interacts with the browser
with the help of something called as RC
server and how it interacts is its uses
a simple HTTP post get request for
communication this was also called as
selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by Webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
Webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium Suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute test cases it is obviously the
successor of the selenium RC which we
talked about because of certain
drawbacks which RC hat so what Webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike RC where the RC required
a server to interact with browser and
the last component is the selenium grid
so selenium grid is used to run multiple
test scripts on multiple machines at the
same time so it helps you in achieving
parallel execution since the selenium
Webdriver with you can only do
sequential execution grid is what comes
into picture where you can do your
parallel execution and why is parallel
execution important because in real time
environment you always have the need to
run test cases in a distributed
environment and that is what grid helps
you to achieve so all this together
helps us to create robust web
application test Automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an IDE RC and grid and as I said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
RC so RC was on its path of deprecation
and Webdriver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of Webdriver and also
the RC so they coexisted from three dot
onwards RC was completely remote and
Webdriver took its place there is also a
four dot version around the corner and
it has more features and enhancements
some some of the features which are
talked about are w3c Webdriver
standardization improved ID and improved
grid now let's look at each of the
components in the selenium Suite
selenium IDE is the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is nothing
but an integrated development
environment for creating your automation
scripts it has a record and Playback
functionality and is a very simple and
easy to use tool it is available as a
Firefox plugin and a Chrome extension so
you can use either of this browser to
record your test scripts it's a very
simple user interface using which you
can create your scripts that interact
with your browser the commands created
in the scripts are called selenis
commands and they can be exported to the
supported programming language and hence
this code can be reused however this is
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitation which any other record
and replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium ID so earlier selenium ID was
only a Firefox extension so we saw that
IDE was available since the selenium
version one selenium ID died with the
Firefox version 55 that was ID was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium ID has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on Chrome as well as as an
add-on on Firefox browser so they
completely revamped this IDE code and
now they have made it available on the
GitHub under the Apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new ID now with this new ID also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side Runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using IDC
on Chrome or Firefox but through command
prompt using your site Runner you can
execute these test cases on any browser
thus by achieving your cross browser
testing control flow statement so
initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while Loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this ID looks and how do we install it
and start working on it so for that let
me take you to my browser so say let's
go to the Firefox browser so on this
browser I already have the ID installed
so when you already have an ID installed
you will see an icon here which says
selenium ID and how do you install this
you simply need to go to your Firefox
add-ons here where it says find more
extension so just type in selenium ID
and search for the sixth section so in
the search results you see the selenium
ID just click on that and now since I've
already installed here it says remove
otherwise for you it is going to give
you an add button here just click on the
add button it will install this
extension once it is installed you
should be able to see this selenium ID
icon here okay so now let's go ahead and
launch this ID so when I click on that
it is going to show me a welcome page
where it's going to give me few options
the first option is this is record a new
test case in a new project so straight
away if you choose this option you can
start recording a test case in which
case it's going to just create a default
project for you which you can save it
later then open an existing project so
you can open if you're already have a
saved project create a new project and
close so I already have an existing
project with me for the demo purpose so
I'll go ahead and open that so I'll say
open existing project and I have created
a simple script what the script does is
it logs me into the Facebook using a
dummy user mail sorry username and
password that's all it's very simple
script with few lines and this is what
it's going to do so what we will simply
do is we'll just run the script and see
how it works for that I'm just going to
reduce the test execution speed so that
you should be able to see every step of
execution here all right so what I'll do
now here is I'll just adjust this window
and I'll just simply say run current
test all right so I'll just get this
side by side so that you should be able
to see what exactly the script is doing
okay so now you are able to see both the
Windows okay so now it's going to type
in your user email here there you go and
now it will enter the password and let
us clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy IDs it is you
are not able to log in here and you are
going to see this error window fine that
is what is the expected output here now
on the ID if you look here after I
execute the test case every statement or
every command which I have used here is
color coded in green so that means this
particular step was executed
successfully and then here in the log
window it will give you a complete log
of this test case right from the first
step till the end and your end result is
it says FB login which is my test case
name completed successful let's look at
few components of this ID the first one
is the menu bar so let's go to our ID
all right so the menu bar is right here
on the top so here is your project name
so either you can add a new project here
or rename your project so since we
already have this project which is named
does Facebook and then on the right you
have options to create a new project
open an existing project or save the
current project and then comes on
toolbar so using the options in this
toolbar you can control the execution of
your test cases so first one here is the
recording button so this is what you use
when you start recording your script and
then on the left you have two options
here to run your test cases the first
one is run all tests so in case you have
multiple test cases written here you can
execute them one by one sequentially by
using this run all test else what you
can do is if you just want to run your
current test this is what you would use
then idea has this debugger option which
you can use to do a step execution so
say for example now whenever I run the
script it's going to execute each and
every command here sequentially so
instead if I just select the first
command and say do step execution all
right so what it does is the moment it
finishes the First Command which is
opening of Facebook correct I think
which is already done here yeah all
right so once this is done it is going
to wait immediately on the second
command and it says paused debugger so
from here you can do whatever you would
like to do in case you want to change
the command here you can do that you can
pause your execution you can resume your
execution here right you can even
completely stop your test execution or
you can just select this to run the rest
of the test case so if we say run the
test case what it is going to do is it's
just going to Simply go ahead and
complete the com complete the test case
now there is another option here which
is you see the timer there which says
test execution speed so to execute your
test cases in the speed you want say
whenever you're developing an automation
script right and say you want to give a
demo so you need to control the speed
sometimes so that the viewer is able to
exactly see all the steps which is being
performed and this gives you an option
to control that complete execution right
so do you see the grading here so we
have somewhere from Fast to completely
slow execution so the pre previous demo
which I showed was I control the speed
and then I executed it so that we could
see every command how it has been
executed all right so what's the next
this is called as an address bar so
whichever Wherever Whenever you enter an
URL here that is where you want to
conduct your test and another thing what
it does is it gives a history of all the
URLs which I've used for running your
test then here is where your script is
recorded So each and every instruction
is displayed here in the order in which
you have recorded the script and then if
you look here you have something called
as login reference so now log is an area
where it records each and every step of
your command as in when they get
executed right so if you see here it
says open https facebook.com and ok so
that means this command was executed
successfully and after the complete test
case is done it gives you whether the
test case passed or filled so in case
there is a failure you'll immediately
see this test case is filled in red
color also there is something called as
reference here for example say if I
click on any of this command the
reference tab what it is going to show
me is a details of this command which I
have used in the script it gives you the
details of the command as well as what
the arguments have been used or how how
is that you need to be using this
particular command okay so now what
we'll do is let's go ahead and write a
simple script using this ID so with this
you'll get an ideas how do we actually
record scripts in ID so for that I have
a use case here a very very simple use
case so what we will do is we will open
amazon.in then we'll search simply
search for say a product iPhone and once
we get that search page where all your
iPhones are displayed we will just do an
assert on the title of the page simple
all right so let's do that so first
thing what I need is an URL okay so
first let me go to my Firefox browser
here and say amazon.in so why I'm doing
this just to Simply get the right URL
absolute URL path here and so that I
don't make any mistakes while typing in
the URL okay so I got this so let me
close all this windows I don't need any
of this let's minimize this all right so
here what I will do in the tests tab
I'll say add a new test and name this
test as uh Amazon search done I'll say
add now I'll enter this URL which I just
copied it from my browser okay and then
I'll just say start recording so what it
did was since I've entered the URL in
this address box it just opened the
amazon.in URL now let's do the test case
so in my test case what I said was I
want to search for iPhone once I have
this I'm just going to click on my
search button so now this gives me a
list of all iPhones and then I said I
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is I have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you'll see the selenium ID options here
so in this I will select assert title
and then I will close this trouser so
that kind of completes my test case so
now take a look at all the steps which
has created for me so it says open slash
because I've already provided the URL
here so either you can replace it with
your regular URL or you can just leave
it as it is so what I will do is since
this is going to be a proper script and
I might be using this to run it from a
command prompt also so I'll just replace
this target with the actual URL and then
what it is doing it is setting a window
size then there are whatever I did on
that particular URL on that website it
has recorded all the steps for me so
this is where it says type into this
particular text box which is my search
box and what did it type iPhone this was
the value which I entered now there was
one more feature which I told you in
this new ID which had which I said it
has a failover mechanism for your
locating techniques now that is what
this is now if you look here this ID is
equal to two tab search textbook this is
nothing but that search box where we
entered the text iPhone and it has
certain identity verification through
which this idea identifies that web
element and that has multiple options to
select that particular search box so
right now what it has used is ID is
equal to two tab search box however if
you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
CSS and the XPath so how does this help
in failovers say tomorrow if Amazon dot
in website changes the ID of this
element right you are not going to come
and rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular ID fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the ID it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of this becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
but let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
assert Title Here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording and then I've also
given a closed browser so right now what
I will do is I'll just comment this out
why because if I just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now I'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now I'll just say run the
current test so your Amazon in is
launched okay it is typed in the iPhone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the log so it's going to be
running log so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
Facebook is also in the same lock so we
will have to see the lock from from
running Amazon search because that's our
test case so if you see here every
command line right was executed
successfully assert title was also done
and your test case was executed
successfully so it passed now what we
will do is on this assert title I'll
just modify this and let's say just add
some text I'll just add double s here
now this by intentionally I am going to
fail this test case just to show you
that whenever there is a test case
failure how does the ID behaves and how
do you get to know the failures all
right so I'll just run the test test
case again so before that let's close
the previous window all right done and
now here I'll also uncomment the close
because anyway it's a failure which I'm
going to see which I should be able to
see it in the logs so I'll close the
browser after the execution of test case
Okay so let's simply go and run the test
case Okay amazon.in is launched it
should search for iPhone now yeah there
you go all right now it should also
close the browser yes let us close the
browser and it has failed now see here
now this is the line where our Command
fit why because the expected title was
not there and if you look in the logs it
says your assert title on amazon.in
failed actual result was something
different and it did not match with what
we had asked it for so this is how
simple it is to use your ID to create
your automation scripts so we saw all
the components of ID we saw the record
button then I showed you the toolbar I
showed you the editor box and also the
test execution log so now let's come to
what are the limitations of this ID with
IDE you cannot export your scripts your
test scripts to web driver scripts this
support is not yet added but it is in
The Works Data driven testing like using
your Excel files or reading data from
the CSV files and passing it to the
script this capability is still not
available also you cannot connect to
database is for reading your test data
or perform any kind of database testing
with selenium Webdriver yes you can also
unlike selenium Webdriver you do not
have a good reporting mechanism with the
ID like say for example test NG or
report entry so that brings us to the
next component of The Suite which is
selenium RC selenium remote control so
selenium RC was developed by Paul
Hammond he refactored the code which was
developed by Json and was credited with
Json as a co-creator of selenium
selenium server is written in Java it is
used to write web application test in
different programming languages as it
supports multiple programming languages
like your Java C sharp Perl Python and
Ruby it interacts with a browser with
the help of an RC server so this RFC
server uses a simple HTTP get and post
request for communication and as I said
earlier also selenium RC was called as
selenium 1.0 overshill but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 and was
completely removed in 3 Auto and it got
replaced by what web driver and we'll
see why this happened and what was that
issue which we had with the RC server so
this is the architecture of selenium
remote control at a very high level so
when Jason Huggins introduced selenium
you know the tool was called as
JavaScript program and then that was
also called as a selenium core so every
HTML has a JavaScript statements which
are executed by web browser and there is
a JavaScript engine which helps in
executing this command now this RCA had
one major issue now what was that issue
say for example you have a test script
say test dot JavaScript here which you
are trying to access elements from
anywhere from the google.com domain so
what used to happen is every element
which is accessible are the elements
which can belong only to google.com
domain like say for example mail the
search or the drive so any elements from
this can be accessible through your test
scripts however nothing outside the
domain of say Google dot com in this
case was accessible say for example if
your test scripts wanted to access
something from yahoo.com this was not
possible and this is due to the security
reasons obviously now to overcome that
the testers what they had to do was they
had to install the selenium core and the
web server which contained your web
application which is under test on the
same machine and imagine if you have to
do this for every machine which is under
test this is not going to be feasible or
even effective all the time and this
issue is called as the same origin
policy now what a same origin policy
issue says is it prohibits a JavaScript
from accessing elements or interacting
with scripts from my domain different
from where it is launched and this is
purely for the security measure so if
you have written a scripts which can
access your google.com or anything
related to google.com these scripts
cannot access any elements outside the
domain like as we said in the example
yahoo.com this was the same origin
policy now to overcome this us what this
gentleman did was he created something
called as selenium remote control server
to trick the browser in believing that
your core your selenium core and your
web application under test are from the
same domain and this is what was the
selenium remote control so if you look
at again a high level architecture or
how did this actually work first you
write your test scripts which is here
right in any of the supported language
like your PHP or your Java or Python and
before we start testing we need to
launch this RC server which is a
separate application so this selenium
server is responsible for receiving the
Cellini's commands and these Salinas
commands are the ones which you have
written in your script it interprets
them and reports the result back to your
test so all that is done through your RC
server the browser interaction which
happens through RC server right from
here to your browser so this happens
through a simple HTTP post and get
request and that is how your RC server
and your browser communicate and how
exactly this communication happens this
RC server it acts like a proxy so say
your test scripts asked to launch a
browser so what happens is this commands
goes to your server and then your RC
server launches the browser it injects
the JavaScript into the browser once
this is done all the subsequent calls
from your test script right from your
test scripts to your browser goes
through your RC and now upon upon
receiving these instructions your
selenium code executes this actual
commands as JavaScript commands on the
browser and then the test results are
displayed back from your browser to your
RC to your test scripts so the same
cycle gets repeated right until the
complete test case execution is over so
for every command what you write in your
JavaScript here or your test script here
goes through a complete cycle of going
through the RC server to the browser
collecting the results again from the RC
server back to your test scripts so this
cycle gets repeated for every command
until your complete test execution is
done so RC had definitely a lot of
shortcomings and what are those so RC
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts which we just
saw so that was an additional setup
since it acts as a mediator between your
commands which is your Cellini's
commands and your browser the
architecture of RC is complicated why
because of its intermediate RC server
which is required to communicate with
the browser the execution of commands
takes very long it is slower we know why
because every command in this takes a
full trip from the test script to your
RC server to the core engine to the
browser and then back to the same route
which makes your overall test execution
very slow lastly the API is supported by
RC are very redundant and confusing so
RC does have a good number of apis
however it is less object oriented so
they are redundant and confusing say for
example say if you want to write into a
text box how and when to use a type key
command or just a type command is always
using another example is some of the
mouse commas using a click or a mouse
door both kind of you know almost
providing a similar functionality so
that is the kind of confusion which
developers used to create hence
selenium RC got deprecated and is no
more available in later selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls web driver was
introduced so while RC was introduced in
2004 web driver was introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006. It's a class platform
testing platform so Webdriver can run on
any platform like say Linux Windows Mac
or even if you have a Ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ID and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the web driver method so
when I do a demo you will understand
what this Webdriver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like RC so it is pretty fast why because
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the RC hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs and this
driver is responsible to make the
browser understand the commands which
you will be passing from the script like
say for example click of a button or you
want to enter some text so through your
script you tell which browser you want
to work with say Chrome and then the
Chrome driver is responsible for
interpreting your instructions and to
execute it on the web application
launched on the Chrome browser so like
RC Webdriver also supports multiple
programming languages in which you can
write your test Scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various Frameworks like test NG
junit and unit and Report entry so when
we talk about the limitations of
Webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various Frameworks and Tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of web
driver at a high level what is in
Webdriver so Webdriver consists of four
major components the first one is we
have got client libraries right or what
we also call it as language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if I go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your Bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all the
stabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that I'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you're
working with Java here what you need to
do is you need to download your Java
language binding so let's go back to the
presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of APs for us to
interact with the browser and when we do
the demo I'll be showing you some of
this APS right and these are nothing but
the rest APS and everything whatever we
do through the script happens through
the rest calls then we have a Json wire
protocol what is Json JavaScript object
notation it is nothing but a standard
for exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
Json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as I said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation so does selenium so let's
look at what these limitations are and
if there are any workarounds for them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like APM
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool however what
selenium provides is a support for
integrating this APM tool which is
nothing but a mobile application
automation tool and using APM and
selenium you can still achieve mobile
application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium I said that with Webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of web driver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about also if you want to
know more details as how do we work with
the grid how do you want to install that
grid so do check out our video on simply
learn website on selenium grid third
limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium Webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more so it does
support some tools like say test engine
report NG and even extend reports which
you can integrate with selenium and
generate beautiful reports powerful
isn't it also there are other challenges
with selenium like selenium is not very
good with image testing especially for
the ones which are designed for web
application automation but then we have
other tools which can be used along with
selenium like autoit and securely so if
you look at all this selenium still
provides a complete solution for your
automation needs and that's the beauty
of selenium and that is why it makes the
most popular tool of today for
automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium RC and the web driver
so RC has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
RC server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser web driver
architecture is pretty simple execution
speed
it is slower in RC and much faster than
Webdriver why because in Webdriver we
have eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that's the RC server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers it
requires an RC server to interact with
the browsers we just talked about it and
whereas Webdriver can directly interact
with the browser
so RC again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant ABS which kept developers
guessing as which API to use for what
functionality however Webdriver offers
pretty clean apis to work with
RC did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in Webdriver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website then type the
selenium in search bar and click on it
and click on the selenium 3.0 training
so we are basically searching for
selenium 3.0 training on the simply
learn website first let's do the steps
manually and then we will go ahead and
write the automation script so let's go
to my browser on my browser what I'll do
is let me first launch the simply learn
website
okay and here what my use case step says
is I need to search for selenium and
click on the search button so once I do
that it is going to give me a complete
list of all kind of selenium trainings
which is available with simpler and what
I'm interested in is the selenium 3.0
training here once I find this on the
web page I need to go and click on that
all right so this is all the steps which
we are going to perform in this use case
okay now so for writing the test cases
I'll be using an ID which is Eclipse
I've already installed my eclipse and
also I have installed selenium in this
instance of my Eclipse all right so if
you can see the reference library folder
here you will see all the jars which are
required for the selenium to work next
another prereq which is required for
selenium and that is your driver files
now every browser which you want to work
with has its own driver file to execute
your selenium scripts and since for this
demo I'll be working with the Firefox
browser I will need a driver file for
Firefox now driver file for Firefox is
the gecko driver which I have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers now where did I download
this from let's go ahead and see that so
if I go back to my browser and if you go
to your selenium HQ dot website you have
to go to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this
you'll see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
I am working on Mac this is the file
which I'm using if you are a Windows
user you need to download this ZIP file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
Firefox or a chrome driver for your
Chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project and just
place the driver files here so these are
the two prereqs for your selenium one is
importing your jar files like this and
then having your drivers downloaded and
keep them under a folder where you can
reference to okay so now we'll go ahead
and create a class I already have a
package created in this project so I'll
use this project and create a new class
so I'll say create new Java class and
let's call this as search training I'll
be using a public static wordman and
I'll click on finish so let's remove
this Auto generated lines as we do not
need all right now the first statement
which you need to write before even you
start writing the rest of your code is
what you need to do is you need to
define or declare your driver variable
using your class web driver so what I
would do is I'll say Webdriver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this ID is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from
org.opensq.selling this is the package
which we will need all right so you have
a driver created which is of the class
web driver and now after this I'm going
to create three methods all right so
first method I will have for launching
the Firefox browser okay and then I will
write a simple method for
searching
selenium training and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing and then third method I'm going
to write is just to close the browser
which I'm going to be opening right so
these are the different methods which
I'll be creating and from the public
static wordman I will just call these
methods one after the other okay so
let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the Firefox browser so I'll say public
void since my return type is null or
there is no return type for this let's
call it as launch browser okay all right
now in this for launching any browser I
need to mention two steps now the first
step is where I need to do a system.set
property okay let's do that first and
then I'll explain what this does I'll
just say system dot set property so this
accepts a key and a value pair so what
is my key here my key here is Webdriver
dot gecko dot driver and I need to
provide a value so value is nothing but
the path to the gecko driver and we know
that this gecko driver which I'm going
to use here is right here in the same
project path under the drivers folder
okay and that is what the path which I'm
going to provide here so here simply I
need to say drivers slash gecko driver
gecko all right done and let me close
this sentence all right now since I am a
Mac User my gecko driver installable is
just the name gecko driver if you're a
Windows user and if you are running your
selenium scripts on the Windows machine
you need to provide a complete path to
this including dot exe because driver
executable on your machines is going to
be gecko driver.exe all right so just
make sure that your path which you
mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is I
need to just say driver is equal to new
Firefox driver okay so this command new
Firefox driver creates an instance of
the Firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the Firefox driver class is
present okay we did that now these two
lines are responsible for launching the
Firefox browser form so this is done so
what's my next step in the use case now
I need to launch the website simply
learn so for that we have a command
called driver dot get driver dot get
what it does is whatever URL you're
going to give it here in this double
quotes as an argument it is going to
launch that particular website and for
us it's a simply learned website so what
I do as a best practices instead of
typing out the URL I go to my browser
launch that URL which I want to test and
I simply copy it come back to your
eclipse and just simply paste it so this
ensures that I do not make any mistakes
in the URL okay so done so our first
method is ready where we are launching
the browser which is our Firefox browser
and then launching the simply learn
website now the next method what is my
next method in my next method I need to
give the search string to search
selenium training on this particular
website now for that we need to do few
things what are those few things let's
go to the website again all right so let
me relaunch this let's close this okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when I did a manual
testing of this I entered the text here
so now since I have to write a script
for this first I need to identify what
this element mentors for that what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to say
right click here and I'll say inspect
element all right now this element let's
see what attribute it has which I can
use for finding this element so I I see
that there is an ID present so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to Simply
use this ID and then I'll just copy this
ID from here go back to Eclipse let's
write a method first so I'll say public
void and what do we give the method name
say search training or just search all
right now in this I need to use a
command called driver dot find element
by ID is what I'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the ID which I copied from the website
is what I'm going to paste here okay and
then what am I going to do on this
element is I need to send that text the
text which I'm going to search for which
is selenium so I'll just say send keys
and whatever text I want to send I need
to give it in double quotes So for that
selenium so this is done so now I've
entered the text texture and after
entering the text I need to click on
this button so for that I need to first
know what that button is so let's
inspect that search button okay now if
you look at the search button other than
the tag which is span and the class name
I do not have anything here all right so
what I can do is I can either use the
class name or I can write an X path
since this is a demo which we have
already used ID locating technique I
would go ahead and use the X path here
so for me to construct an X path I will
copy this class first okay and then I
already have a crow path installed on my
Firefox so I'll use the crow path and
first test my X bar so I'll just say
double slash let's see what was that
element it has a span tag okay so I'll
have to use span and at class equal to
and I'll just copy the class name here
and let's see if it can identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so I'll just use this x path in my code
so I'll go back to eclipse and I'll say
driver dot find element y dot X path and
the X path which I just copied from
cropath is what I'm going to paste here
and what is the action I need to do here
I need to say click done so I have
reached a stage where I have entered
this selenium okay and then I have
clicked on the search button once I do
this I know that expected result is I
should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.2 training okay and
I should be able to click on that so for
that again I need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag H2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so I would again would like
to use a x path here now this time while
using the X path I am going to make use
of a text functionality so that I can
search for this particular text so I'll
simply copy this I'll go to my Crow path
the tag is H2 so I'll say simply H2 okay
and here I'll say text equal to and this
is the text which I copied I missed out
that yes there so I'm just going to add
an S okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see your blue dotted line it
is able to show us which element it is
identified so I'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ID Eclipse so now
here what I need to do is I'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot X path and paste the X path which
we just did and then again I have to do
a click operation done all right so
technically we have taken all the steps
of the use case and we have written the
commands for that now let's add an
additional thing here say after coming
to this page after finding this we want
to uh say print the title of this page
now what is the title of this page if
you just hover your mouse on this it
says online and classroom training for
professional certification courses
simply now so what I will do is after
doing all these operations I will just
print out this page title on our console
so for that I have to just do this drive
fiber dot so let's do a sys out so I'll
say sys out
system.out.println okay and here I would
say let's add a text here the page title
is and then let's append it with driver
dot get title so this is the command
which we'll be using to fetch the page
title done now what is the last method I
need to add just to close the browser
all right so let me add a method here
I'll say public void close browser and
it's a one single command which I need
to call I'll say driver dot quit Okay
and then I need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so I let me use my class name which is
this so I'm going to create an object
obj is equal to new class name and then
using this object first is I need to
call the method launch browser and then
I'll call the method search right and
then I'll call the method close browser
so technically our script is is ready
with all the functionality which we
wanted to cover from our use case now
there are few other tweaks which I need
to do this and I'll tell you why I need
to do this now for example after we
click here right after we click on the
search if you observed on your website
it took a little while before it listed
out all the selenium trainings for us
and usually when you are actually doing
it you wait for the selenium 3.0
training to be available and then you
click on that now same thing you also
need to tell your scripts to do that you
need to tell your scripts to wait for a
while until you start seeing the
selenium 3.0 training or it appears on
your web page there are multiple ways to
do that in your script and it is a part
of overall synchronization what we call
where we use kind of implicit and
explicit kind of favorites now since
this is a demo for demo purpose what I'm
going to do is I am going to use a
command curve thread.sleep and I'm just
going to give an explicit weight of say
three seconds so you can use this Main
only for the demo purposes you can use a
thread.sleep command now this
thread.sleep command needs us to handle
some exceptions so I'm just going to
click on ADD throws declaration and say
interrupted exception now same thing
I'll have to do it in my main function
also okay so let's do that and complete
it all right so this is done so by doing
this what am I doing I'm ensuring that
before I click on the selenium three dot
training we are giving enough time for
the script to wait until the web page
shows this link to the selenium 3.0
training that's one thing I'm doing all
right and also now since you are going
to be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly I'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what I'll do is I'll just give a
simple thread.sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds which should be good enough okay
at three seconds weight should be good
enough here so that we should be able to
see how exactly this works on your
browser when we execute this okay now
our complete script is ready so what
I'll do is I'll just save the script and
then we will simply run the script so to
run the script I just say right click
run as Java application okay it says ask
me to select and save I have saved the
script now so let's observe how it runs
okay the simply learn.com the website is
launched so the selenium text has been
entered in the search box it has clicked
on the search okay all right so now it
did everything whatever we wanted it to
do all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what I have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what I'll do
since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium 3. training or
not I'll just comment out the closed
browser uh the command okay so we will
not call the close browser so that the
browser remains open and we get to see
whether did it really find the training
link or not okay so let me close this
window we don't need this Firefox window
close all tabs and then I'll just
re-execute the script so I'll say run as
Java application so save the file okay
simplylearn.com is launched so search
text is entered now it's going to click
on the search button yes all right so
we've got the search results it should
click on selenium 3.0 training and yes
it is successfully able to click on that
all right so now it's not going to close
the browser because we have commented on
that line however it did print us the
title here all right so this is a simple
way of using the selenium Scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with Webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by Patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallelly so design
is in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run tests and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has as a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
systems like as in this picture you
could say one of them is a Windows
machine one of them is a Mac machine and
another one is say a Linux machine so
your requirement is to run the test on
all supported browsers and operating
systems like the one which is depicted
in this picture so what you have to do
is first thing is you configure a Master
machine or what you also call it as a
hub by running something called a
selenium Standalone server and this
Talent Standalone server can be
downloaded from the selenium HQ website
using the server you create a hub
configuration that is this node and then
you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your Standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so I'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our selenium HQ website so you
can see here right on the top it says
selenium Standalone server and this is
the latest version available so you just
need to download once you download this
keep a version of this one on your
master machine that is your Hub and this
should also be present on your node
machines and there is a certain command
which you can use to install the server
as a node and as a master depending on
your configuration so once that is done
you have your master and your master or
the Hub and the notes created your
master can control on which nodes you
want to execute test now say if this is
a Mac machine this is a Windows machine
through your master or your Hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what tests then also you could
have a multiple combination of tests
like say for example smoke test to be
run on all these nodes that's the kind
of configuration you can create or a
certain component and test to be run on
say only Windows 10 with an edge browser
or say regression test on Mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the Hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the Node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the Node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it intends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does is grid have now
the first one it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications it is pretty static each
server is configured in advance with a
subset of required browser instances
available so if you want to vary this
you'll need to reconfigure so any
configuration tomorrow on any machines
you want to change it cannot be done
automatically you need to completely
reconfigure that node and then add it
back to the grid thirdly although it is
available to run on Virtual servers it
is actually not designed as a cloud
native application and because of as a
result of this it isn't optimized to
take advantage of things like say
distributed storage or dynamic scaling
or even automatic failover so these are
some of the limitations of the grid
advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy of course since there is no
manual execution your test can run
faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution and you can run or
execute large volumes of test within a
very short time frame let's take an
example say before just before the
release of your product say during the
last lap of your testing you find a bug
and of course it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and you want to
run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second Advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support So this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping in achieving a
very broad test coverage and we also saw
that pretty easy to use tool right so
you can check out all our videos and you
can it's just a matter of time that you
can Master the skill of writing your
automation scripts reusability of course
like any programming language it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy well again
let's see an overall what are the
limitations of selenium itself now since
selenium is open source that is one of
the biggest Advantage now there is a
little disadvantage which comes with
that and what is that you do not have
much technical support because it's an
open source code however there are loads
and loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like APM for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like autoit and securely which can be
integrated with selenium selenium
Webdriver has limited a limited
reporting capability but again it does
provide us support for integrating tools
like test NG report NG and extend report
it does not have test management
capabilities it need not right not one
tool need not have each and everything
what is required but there is always a
way to integrate it so selenium does
provide a way to integrate any of the
test management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation simply launch
postgraduate program in devops with
Caltech University in collaboration with
IBM should be your right choice for more
details on this program please use the
link in the description box below hello
and welcome to continuous integration
tutorial using Jenkins my name is
chidanand and I am with the simply learn
team today let's get started with
Jenkins Jenkins in my opinion is one of
the most popular continuous integration
servers of recent times what began as a
hobby project by a developer working for
Sun Microsystems way back in early or
mid-2000s has gradually and eventually
evolved into a very very powerful and
robust automation servers it has a wider
option since it is released under MIT
license and is almost free to use
Jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
Jenkins because using plugins one can
connect Jenkins to anything and
everything thing under the sun with that
introduction let's get into what all
will be covered as a part of this
tutorial I will get into some of the
prerequisites required for installing
Jenkins post which I will go ahead and
install Jenkins on a Windows box there
are few first-time configurations that
needs to be done and I will be covering
those as well so once I have Jenkins
installed and configured properly I will
get into the user administrative part I
create few users and I will use some
plugins for setting up various kinds of
access permissions for these users I
will also put in some freestyle jobs
freestyle job is nothing but a very very
simple job and I will also show you the
powerfulness of Jenkins by scheduling
this particular job to run based upon
time schedule I will also connect
Jenkins with GitHub GitHub is our source
code where source code repository where
I've got some repositories put up there
so using Jenkins I will connect to
GitHub pull up a repository that is
existing on GitHub onto the Jenkins box
and run few command chance to build this
particular repository that is pulled
from GitHub sending out emails is a very
very important configurations of Jenkins
or any other continuous integration
server for that matter Whenever there is
any notifications that has to be sent
out as a part of either a build going
bad or building good or building
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
continuous integration servers to be
sending out notifications so I will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure Jenkins for sending out emails
I will also get into a scenario where I
would have a web application a
maven-based Java web application which
will be pulled from a GitHub repository
and I will deploy it onto a tomcat
server the Tomcat server will be locally
running on my system eventually I will
get into one other very very important
topic which is the Master Slave
configuration it's a very very important
and pretty interesting topic where
distributed builds is achieved using a
Master Slave configuration so I will
bring up a slave I will connect the
slave with the master and I will also
put in job and kind of delegate that
particular job to the slave
configuration finally I will let you
know how to use some plugins to backup
your Jenkins so Jenkins has got a lot of
useful information set up on it in terms
of the build environments in terms of
workspace all this can be very very
easily backed up using a plugin so this
is what I'm going to be covering as a
part of this tutorial Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic Word file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt effect
earlier on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using Jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a Ctrl C
and then bring down this prompt and your
Jenkins server would be down other older
versions of Jenkins were run popularly
using this way in which you already have
a Java based web server running up and
running so you kind of drop in this war
file into the root folder or the httpd
root folder of your web server so
Jenkins would explode and kind of bring
up your application all user credentials
or user Administration is all taken care
of by the Apache or the Tomcat server or
the web server on which Jenkins is
running this was a very older way of
running but still some people use it
because if they don't want to maintain
two servers if they already have a Java
web server which it's being nicely
maintained and backed up Jenkins can run
attached to it all right so either ways
it doesn't matter how we're going to
bring up your Jenkins instance the way
we're going to operate Jenkins is all
going to be very very same or similar
one with the subtle changes in terms of
user Administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
Administration otherwise all the
commands are all the configuration or
the way in which I'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is run in
Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the
recommended RAM for running Jenkins and
also like any other open source toolsets
when you install jdk ensure that you set
in the environment variable Java home to
point to the right directory this is
something very specific to jdk but for
any other open source tools that you've
installed there is always a preferred
environment variable that you got to set
in which is specific to that particular
tool that you're going to use this is a
generic thing that is there for you know
for any other open source projects
because the way open source projects
discover themselves is using this
environment variables so as a general
practice or a good practice always set
this environment variables accordingly
so I already have GDK 1.8 installed on
my system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk 1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
will not get into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so
if you get into these environment
variables
all right so I have just sitting a Java
home variable
if you say this C colon program files
Java jdk 1.8 this is where my my Java is
located see program files C program
files Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run Java
or Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java hyphen version
all right and Java C yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download all right so what
I want is yes this is the war file with
a generic War file that I was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows MSI
installer so go ahead and download this
MSI installer I already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start uh Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs deposit
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
I don't need to do any of this thing so
I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes in into
the Jenkins configuration C colon
program files is good for me yeah this
is where all my destination folder and
all the configuration specific to it
goes I'm happy with this I don't want to
change this I would just say go ahead
and click installation
foreign
so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done so and by default Jenkins Launches
on the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I will have to just copy
this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not correct it will crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see there is a whole
lot of plugins which are bare essential
plugin that is required for Jenkins in
order to run properly so Jenkins as a
part of the installation would get all
these plugins and then install it for
you this is a good combination to kind
of begin with and mind you at this
moment Jenkins needs lots of bandwidth
in terms of network so in case your you
know your network is not so good few of
these plugins would kind of fail and
these plugins are all you know all
available on openly or or mirrored sites
and sometimes some of them may be down
so do not worry in case some of these
plugins kind of fail to install you'll
get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just ensure that you
know at least most or 1995 of all these
plugins are installed without any
problems let me pause the video here for
a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that I get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I get a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you would kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line UI is
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure a system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can you
can kind of visualize it like a thread
that can be run on this particular
instance as a thumb rule if at all
you're on a single core system number of
executors two should be good enough in
case at any point in time if there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually Jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the CPU usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the Jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configuration that
I'm going to change here all of these
look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine the scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just give
you an example in case your source code
is a Java source code and assuming that
you know because in this a demo this is
my laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install GDK on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
Jenkins runs it will not be able to find
these tools for building your task and
it'll crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
managing games let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
which hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root DN password
or the manager DN and the manager
password and all these details in case
you want to connect your Jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization
but for now since I don't have any of
these things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so I will
just say you know first job this is good
for me I just give a name for my job I
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me I don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on a Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once I save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
alright so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you would see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
it should be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and now put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering our hook or a web hook
kind of a triggering later on but for
now what I want to do I want to ensure
that this job that I'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute I want this
job to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and she's asking me do you
really mean every minute oh yeah I want
to do this every minute let me save this
and how do I check whether it gets
triggered every minute or not I just
don't do anything I'll just wait for a
minute and if at all everything goes
well Jenkins would automatically trigger
my second job in a minute's time from
now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role product specific growth I
can have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into manage Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for it to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins all right so let
me come back to available and I would
want to search for my role based access
plugin so I would say search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart Jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you would need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now all right so this comes
in because of my installation of my role
based plugin so this is what I would
want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I've installed
the role based access plugin I would
need to just set it up and check that
you know I would go ahead and create
some roles and ensure that I assign
users as per these roles all right so
let me go to
manage Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configured configure Global
Security is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer
and I'm adding this role at a global
role level so I would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a help on what what are these uh
you know permissions specific to so what
I want is like you know it sounds a
little you know different but I would
want to give very very little
permissions for the developer so from an
Administration perspective I would just
want him to have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that's looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job I'll
check you know have read only access to
the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run any
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I created a rule I still don't have
any users that is there on the system so
let me go ahead and create some user on
the system
that's not here I would say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured out of the
system and developer one is a user that
I have configured so still have not set
any rules for this particular user yet
so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer one to this
particular Global Rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and this permissions can
be you know fine-grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that I had set in let
me quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
white bucket is one of the git servers
has so many plugins that is available
okay so bottom line Jenkins without
plugins is nothing so plugins is the
heart of Jenkins for you to connect or
for in order to connect Jenkins with any
of the containers or any of the other
tool sets you would need the plugins if
you want to connect or you want to build
a repository which has got Java and
Maven you would need to install Maven
and GDK on your Jenkins instance if at
all you're looking for a net build or a
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect Jenkins build build a job on
Jenkins and push it to sonar Cube and
get sonar Cube to run analysis on that
and get back the results in Jenkins all
of these works very well because of the
plugins now with that let me connect our
Jenkins instance to GitHub I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up the https URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
Java file how do I build my Java file
how do I compile my Java file I just say
Java C and the name of my class file
which is hello.java and how do I run my
Java file I would say Java and hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here this is a git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would sure because
the plugin is already there SVN perforce
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
these particular Source control tools
okay so I would copy the https URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password alright so I would say the
username this is my username and this is
my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I gonna do the step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system on
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and it
can you can build a war file and even
deploy it into some other server for now
what we're going to use Maven is just
for building and creating a package out
of this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the link is
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download I'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
Tomcat all right so download Maven first
look at the various ways in which you
can kind of download this mobile there
is zip files
binary zip files and archive files so
what I've done is I've just already
downloaded Maven and if you see I've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which I have unzipped my maven so
as you know Maven again is is one open
source build tool so you'll have to set
in a few configurations and set up the
path so mvn hyphen iPhone version if I
specify this after setting my path my
one should work and if at all I Echo M2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my one
oop it is already set here so once you
unzip my one just set this M2 home
variable to the directory where you
unzip your my one also just set the path
to this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your Maven
executables are all formed
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable Maven is running
perfectly fine on my system I just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this is where you download Tomcat server
and um I already have the server
downloaded again this doesn't need any
installation I just unzip it here and it
kind of has a bin and configuration I
have made some subtle changes in the
configuration first and foremost Tomcat
server also by default runs on port 8080
since we already have our Jenkins server
running on port 8080 we cannot let
Tomcat run on the same port there will
be a port Clash so what I've done I have
configured Tomcat to use a different
port so if I go to this configuration
file here there is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow programmatic access to the Tomcat
server so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll Empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open a command prompt here and there's
a startup.bat
pretty fast it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go tomcatel is up and
running now this is running on Port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is operating that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
mbn
web app I'll call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of Market repository is
uh this guy https URL okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so a simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a word file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this Warfare was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server
again I would need a small plugin to do
this because I need to connect Tomcat
with my Jenkins server let me go ahead
and install the plugin for the container
deployment so I would go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I would say this web application War
file that is already built so I would
need to configure this plugin to pull up
this war file and deploy it onto the
Tomcat server for deploying onto the
Tomcat server I will use the credentials
of the user that I've created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my Tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer okay so
let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deploy credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so take the war file
that is fine found in this particular
folder and then you know context path
the same in web app use the deployer
deployment credentials and get into this
localhost which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well
so
the context path was a main web app so
if I type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date time stamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkinson's test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different IP that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you are heavily
reliant on kitchen server you don't want
your Jenkins server to go down so that's
wherein you kind of start Distributing
the load that is there on the Jenkins
server so you primarily have a server
which is just a placeholder or like a
master who will take in all the kind of
jobs and what you'll do is based upon
trigger that has happened to the job or
whichever job needs to be built he if at
all he can delegate these jobs onto some
of the machines or some other sleeves
you know that's a wonderful thing to
have okay use case one use case two
assuming that you know if you have a
Jenkins server that is running on a
Windows box or on a Linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
Windows uh you know Windows based.net
kind of a projects where you would need
a Windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
Linux Linux based systems you also have
a Mac you you support some sort of an
apps or something that is built on Mac
OS you would need to build you know Mac
based system as well so how are you
going to support all these needs so
that's wherein a beautiful concept of
Master Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there's a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I'll set up
a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guide so I enable this guy instead of
making the default the configuration was
disabled so I make him random I make him
you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now I've configured ours
made a setting for the master so that
the jlp port is kind of opened up so let
me go ahead and you know create an agent
so I'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server and Jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to a Jenkins master so I would
say new node I would give a name for my
node I would say windows node because
both of these are windows only so that's
fine I'll just give an identifier saying
that Windows node I would say this is a
permanent agent I would say okay so if
you see the name let me just copy this
name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86. C colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave and I'm
going to run it from here so this is the
directory in which I am going to
provision my slave node so I'm going to
copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or sleep so I just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they're allowed to specify this
particular level so imagine this way if
I have a bunch of Windows my system I
name it as Windows star anything that
says from Windows I can give a regular
expression and say that anything that
matches Windows run this particular task
there if I have some MAC machines I name
all these Mac agents as Mac star or
something like that and I can delegate
all tasks you know saying that start
with whatever starts with mac and this
node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web star because we gotta
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory I think
nothing else is required availability
yes will keep this agent yeah online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there I need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
path there I also want to download this
alien.jar
I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 18.jar I copy this or I cut
this I come back to my folder my Jenkins
node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command from right here and then lost
it so I'm saying in the same folder
where there is agent.jar I'm going to
launch this a particular agent Java
hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is the
URL of my server in case the server and
client are on different locations or
different IPS there are specified IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it's connected very well it seems
to have connected very well so let me
come back to my Jenkins instance and see
you know if at all you see earlier this
was not connected now let me refresh
this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials or the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running or
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully we have
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
Jenkins node or the Jenkins slave so any
task that I'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it will create a workspace right here
all right so good so let me just come
back and let me kind of put up a new
task here I will say that you know
delegate job is good I see freestyle
project I'm going to create a very very
simple job here
I don't want it kind to get or anything
like that let me just create a very very
simple
Echo
relegated to the
slave negative two I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that I've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular sleep we give a label right
so now I'm going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
you know Windows node so this job will
be delegated around there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it ran
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it creates a new workspace
delegate a job it put in here so my old
or the my primary Master job is in SQL
program files under Jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of Master Slave configuration or
distributed build in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up the one quick way to
do that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a colon program files
colon Jenkins directory because that's
where our whole Jenkins configuration is
present but we would don't want to do
that let's use some plugins for taking
up a backup so let me go to manage
Jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use so this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder uh this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens there are
too many jobs that is running on the
server it can kind of slow down your
Jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things and if the files are being
changed at that moment instead a bit
problematic for Jenkins so typically you
backup your servers only when there is
very less load or typically you try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so I'm going to back up all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the amount of artifacts possibly
I don't want this guy I would just say
save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular
configurations so how do I do that I
just come back to my managing cans
come back to backup manager and I'll say
restore Hudson or Jenkins configuration
simply launch postgraduate program in
devops with Caltech University in
collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details on this
program please use the link in the
description box below let's get started
with what is jmeter
jmeter is an open source software which
is a hundred percent pure Java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic it was originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions
to simplify let's assume that someday
your team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users what would be the first thing
that comes to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with computers and
access to the internet and accessing the
same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter Rises
so what jmeta actually does is that it
simulates it will simulate real user
behaviors and perform load tests on a
server group of servers Network or
object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that Java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having Java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as Linux
Windows Mac us or even Ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
Java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type Java hyphen
version we can see that Java is present
in our system here it will show the
version of java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter go
to Google Chrome and type jmeter
download
now go to the official Apache jmeter
website and go to the binary sections in
the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here the bin
folder contains the jmeter script file
for starting jmeter
now it's time for us to launch a meter
but before we launch a meter we need to
know that there are typically two types
of modes in which jmeter can be launched
the GUI mode and the non-gui mode the
non-gui mode May refer to two types the
first being running jmeter in the server
mode and the second refers to running
jmeter in the command line
and if we talk about the GUI mode then
the GUI mode has a limitation which
slows down the CPU utilization while
running the recorded script but GUI mode
of jmeter is perfect for adding and
editing new configuration elements
thread groups and Samplers as a result
of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the GUI mode so to open the GUI mode
inside this bin folder select the
jmeter.bat file double click on this
file this may take a while and then the
jmeter window will open up on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configuration
of that element are added as we see on
the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here the test
plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests listeners and everything will
be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first J meter now when you click outside
this window section you can see the
element name will change otherwise you
can just save this and also the name
will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups right click on
first J meter here and select the add
option then in this option select the
threads option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test so let's name this thread
group to be jmeter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want then there is this number of
threads where you can choose the number
of users you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to Run infinite number
of times
there is also a scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
tests and time
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
the next step is to go to First J meter
and again to go to add in the boxer
appears select Samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the HTTP request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the URL from
here
come back to the jmeter window and paste
it in the server name box keep in mind
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box since
we have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our HTTP test is ready we'll
perform the test on it to determine what
the result of the test will be we need
to add some more test elements we shall
again right click on first J meter go to
The Listener options then in the Box we
can check the different type of reports
that jmeter provides us for now we shall
select two of these let's choose view
results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the Third Way is you can
right click on first J meter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be 1 there's just one entry
in both the results now let's try one
more thing we shall go to jmeter and
change the number of threads and the
loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
10. and now run the test after running
the test we shall see the results in the
table and see the testing being
performed and the same happens in the
case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since a loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link let's get started
with what is performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base the
main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload the main purpose of performance
testing is to identify and eliminate
performance bottlenecks in the software
application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed here it
identifies whether the response of the
application is fast or not then comes
scalability where the maximum user load
is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads now we know what is
performance testing let us understand
why if we need performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time reliability resource and
scalability are also important factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and poor usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application means speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads application
sent to Market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and fail to meet the
expected sales goals now we know the
relevance and need for performance
testing let's look at the typescript
performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing let's have a look at all the six
types of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and Peak usage and
applications performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently with an accepted Endurance
on different user loads here the main
consideration is the maximum load the
application can hold before the
application starts behaving abruptly
then another consideration is regarding
how much data the data base can handle
before the system crashes the second
type of performance testing is stress
testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how much load A system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test is started with a
load for which the application has
already been tested then more load is
added slowly to stress the system the
point at which we start seeing servers
not responding to the request as
considered the breaking point here the
major considerations are the maximum
load to a system can sustain before it
breaks down then how is the system
broken down and how will the system be
able to recover once it has crashed
we also see in how many ways a system
can break and which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load moving
forth the next type is volume testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or study
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after 5 to 10 years the data stored
in the database of the website is much
more and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing
so capacity testing is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects here the main concerns
are if the application would be able to
support the future load if the
environment is capable of standing the
upcoming increased load and what are the
additional resources required to make
the environment capable enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many uses or transactions of a given
web application is capable of supporting
and will perform well during this
testing resources such as processor
capacity
Network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity Etc are considered and altered
to meet the goal to consider an
excellent example of capacity testing we
can see the case of online banking
moving forward the next type of testing
is the reliability testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal State the last type of testing
is scalability testing scalability
testing is a type where the application
is determined if it would be able to
scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load now when we
have learned the types of performance
testing we must learn the process of
performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement Gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
Gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the application's
architecture Technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements Etc the second
step in the process is selection of
tools
after the previous step POC or proof of
concept is done with the available tools
the proof of concept is a sort of
demonstration of real-time activity but
in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tools cost the protocol that the
application is using the technology is
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
Etc now the third step the third step is
the performance test plan in reference
to the above two steps test planning and
designing are conducted the process of
test planning involves information on
how the performance test is going to
take place like the test environment
workload Hardware
Etc moving forth the fourth step is
performance test development in this
step the use cases for the identified
functionalities are created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval once the
clients approve the use case the script
development begins these scripts are
validated against several different
users and parallel to script creation
the performance Team sets up the test
environment the performance team also
takes care of metadata through scripts
if the client does not take up that
activity so the next step is performance
test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution this step aims to
validate whether the given performance
metrics are achieved during the test or
not then the sixth step is execution of
tests the scenario is designed according
to the load model in controller or
performance center initially the tests
are not executed with maximum users that
are in the load model the test execution
is done in incremental order let's say
there are thousand users then the
scenario will begin testing from 100
then go to 250 then 350 and so on it
will gradually increase and go up to
1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis the
test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred then the
final and the last step in performance
testing process is the report the test
results should be simplified so that
conclusion is clearer and should not
create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point now that we
know the performance testing the next
important topic to discuss is the
understanding of performance testing
metrics the first is processor usage
which refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threats second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is test
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving forth
the next metric is the private bytes it
is the number of bytes a process has
allocated that can be shared amongst the
other processes these are used to
measure memory leaks and usage then
comes the committed memory this is the
amount of virtual memory used then the
next metric we have is the response time
it is the time between when the user
enters a request to turn to the first
character of the response is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives requests per second moving
forth the next metric is the hit ratios
the hit ratios are concerned with the
number of SQL statements that are
handled by cached data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts hits per second
CPU Interruption per second this queue
length Etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top 5
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
Runner or HP load Runner as the name
suggests the load Runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing the second tool in our
list is web load web load is one of the
best testing tools for stress and load
testing the next tool in our list is
load UI load UI is a great testing tool
to map the scalability and speed of the
target product the fourth tool in our
list is new load it is one of the
fastest testing tools with a speed of
around 10 times the traditional testing
tools that are integrated seamlessly
into our existing software with a wide
array of tests the last tool in our list
is the Apache jmeter Apache jmeter is
one of the best and most used testing
tools in the market right now it is
highly capable of creating a large
number of virtual users working on web
server moving forward we shall talk
about jmeter and understand why jmeter
is preferred over all the other
performance testing tools in the market
so moving forth let's see what J meter
is J meter or Apache jmeter is an open
source software that has 100 pure Java
application the application is designed
to load or test functional behavior and
measure performance jmeter is originally
designed for testing web applications
but has since expanded to other test
functions to understand the concept of
jmeter let us assume that someday your
team leads tell you to perform
performance testing on some website like
Facebook or google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to Internet and
accessing the same website now just
imagine the infrastructure requirement
when this testing has to be done for 10
000 users this is when a need for
software like jmeter arises so what
jmeter does is it actually simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers Network or
object now let's have a look at some
reasons why geometer is used for load
testing we have divided these reasons
into six parts the first one is it's
free of cost second one is performance
testing of applications next one
platform independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
Playback and finally six is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have is free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as six to seven figures per license
here jmeter is free of cost very
intuitive and has all the possibilities
you need to automate your work then the
second reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeter can conduct
load and performance tests for many
different servers and server types web
HTTP and https database via jdbc ldap
and JMS the third reason is
platform Independence
jmeter is written and developed using
Java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts Java virtual
machine for example Windows Linux Mac
Etc the next reason we have is that
jmeter is customizable since jmeta is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize whenever needed
jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding in defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis these Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request to be sent to the host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions and moving forth
the following reason is recording and
Playback
the application provides record and
Playback options enabled with the drag
and drop feature making the application
faster and easier the next and the last
reason on our list is incredible
Community Support jmeter is an open
source tool with a brilliant community
that keeps adding features and supports
users who run into issues and problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on J meter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with user needs and requirements finally
let's have a look into the demo that
shows the working of jmeter
so the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter dot path file
double click on this file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
I have rename this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add then go to thread or users
and select thread group
let's name this as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the user hits third there is
a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to run in finite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test and
time let's make the number of threads to
B2 and let's make the loop count to be
100. the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to add option and go to
the sampler option in the menu that
appears select the HTTP request option
here on the screen there is a server
name or IP Box we have to give the
server name or the IP in that let's pick
up a website and place the link in the
box which will use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
onto the server name box keep in mind we
don't need to give the HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page and let's
rename this HTTP request as simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in jmeter and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the ad select listener option
and go to the view results entry option
then again right click on the listener
option and choose graph results and for
the third listener again right click and
select the view results in the table
option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the Run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first J
meter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this jmeter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count to 100 so the
test will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency and in the tree option when we
click on the test we can see a lot of
information appearing on the screen
these are again several performance
testing metrics and in the graph results
we can see the graph coming up on the
screen now which represents the test
taking place with respect to the IP
address thread and loop counts so what
geometer exactly does is creates a
request and sends it to the server once
it receives the service response it
collects them and visualizes those
details in a chart or graph after that
it processes the service response and
finally it generates the test results in
several formats such as text XML Json so
that the tester can analyze the data
let's get started with what is load
testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together here
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines A System's performance
according to real life conditions to
give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or test a mail
server with thousands of concurrent
users or to test a word processor by
making a change in a large volume of
data this helps to know whether the
existing infrastructure is capable of
running the application or not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to Hardware like CPU
maximization Network bottleneck memory
limitation Etc and it also identifies
the issues in software configurations
such as web server application server
database server Etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to data mining
user demands and satisfaction several
tools make load testing possible such as
Apache jmeter web load load UI load
Runner new load load ninja Etc
here in this session we shall be using
jmeter for load testing so jmeta or
Apache geometer is open source software
that is 100 pure Java application the
application is designed to load or test
functional behavior and measure
performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against heavy load multiple
and concurrent user traffic it was
originally designed for testing web
applications but has since expanded to
other test functions to simplify let's
assume that someday your team leads tell
you to perform performance testing for
some websites like yahoo.com or
google.com for 100 users what would be
the first thing that comes to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with 100 computers
and access the internet and accessing
the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers Network or object next let's
have a look at some reasons why jmeter
is used for load testing we have divided
these reasons into six parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications platform independent
customizable recording and Playback and
Community Support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost one of
the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here jmeter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
test for many different server types
like web HTTP and https database via
jdbc ldap and JMS the third important
reason is its platform independent in
nature jmeter is written and developed
using Java programming language to run
on any environment or workstation that
accepts a Java virtual machine for
example Windows Linux Mac Etc
the next reason we have is jmeter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
cleaner and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
you everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis the Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request is to be sent to a host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions moving forward
the following reason is recording and
Playback the application provides record
and Playback options enabled with the
drag and drop features making the
application faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible Community Support jmeta is
an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems this ensures new users always
have someone to answer their questions
and long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter also having an open
source tool ensures it keeps getting
better and always in line with users
needs and requirements now after we know
about jmeter and the reasons to use shea
meter let's understand the process to
perform load testing with a Hands-On
demo the only thing that is kept in mind
before this demo is we must have a fully
functional jmet on our system and by now
we know that jmeter can be used in any
operating system like Linux Windows Mac
OS and Ubuntu in this demo we should
look into both graphical user and
non-graphical user interface mode of
load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter dot embed file double click on
this file this might take a while and
then the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of the element that are added as we are
on the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the scene here the
test plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests the listeners and everything
will be stored here so the first step is
to add listeners for that go to test
plan right click on the test plan go to
add then go to threads users and select
a thread group the test group refers to
the users that are used or created or
needed to run this test it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period in seconds
option that states the time gap between
the user's hits then the third one there
is a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to Run infinite times there is also
a scheduler here to help you schedule
the start time and the test and time for
now let's leave everything to be only
one
the next step is to add the HTTP request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option and go to the HTTP
request option here on the screen there
is a server name or IP Box we have to
give the server name or the IP in that
let's pick a website and place the link
in that box we should use the simply
learns website here go to Simply learns
website and copy the URL from there now
we have copied the simply learns URL now
let's come back to the jmeter window and
paste it in the server name box keep in
mind that we don't need to give up the
HTTP or https since these are protocols
which will come in the other box and
they will be automatically taken in the
HTTP request case
so this is what I was talking about now
let's rename this name as simply
moving forward let's create one more
HTTP request for that again right click
on the thread group select samples and
select HTTP request and go to Simply
glance website again and there we have
the resource linked go to that link and
copy the URL then place that URL in the
server or IP address box
we shall remove the HTTP from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the HTTP request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more HTTP
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the HTTP request option again to
add one more link to the server and IP
address go to Simply learns website go
to the corporate training link now copy
the URL and go back to the jmeter window
and paste that URL in the IP Box now cut
the corporate training part from the
link and paste it to the other path box
we shall again rename this HTTP request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
loadtesting.jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is used to provide the outputs of the
load test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins The Listener
we will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option now
it's time to run the test and check the
load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the Run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
jmeter and then choose run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
after we run the test we shall go to the
check the results of the test in the
view results entry section we can see
the green symbol that states the test
has successfully completed since we had
left all the values to be one in the
beginning that's why there is just one
test for each HTTP request now let's
increase the load and let's change some
numbers let's make the number of threads
to be 10 ramp up the periods to V2 and
the loop going to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
10 for each user the test will run 10
times so here on the screen we can see
the time taken and the number of tests
being performed on the status of each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode now perform the same test and
non-graphical user mode which will
remove the listener so let's remove the
view results entry
after this we will go to the command
prompt then in the command prompt we
shall put the pin folder path in the
Apache jmeter folder let's go to the bin
folder and copy the location from here
and now paste the path in the command
prompt and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is The Hyphen n hyphen T
and hyphen L here The Hyphen n
represents the known graphical user
interface mode hyphen T is used to
specify the location of the test script
hyphen L is used to specify the location
of our output result now go to the
location where our jmx file is stored
let's search for the load testing.jmx
file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the name of
the filebit.jmx
now go back to the folder and make a DOT
CSV file make an Excel spreadsheet and
rename it with DOT CSV extension now
copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the CSV file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the Run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the load
testing is successful in the
non-graphical mode without any errors
this is what we had in this demo we saw
the load testing and graphical user
interface and non-graphical user
interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the HTTP request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter its default behavior
is to read and process samples from a
CSV file to generate HTML files it
generates the report and at the end of
the load test are on demand the
dashboard reports provide metrics like
the APD ex or application performance
index the dashboard also provides a
statistics table response time over time
response times percentiles over time
active threads over time and response
times and percentiles we shall learn
about dashboards and more in the
forthcoming videos in this video we
learned how critical is load testing in
the software testing process and how it
ensures High user satisfaction a
successful load testing will help to
release high quality software if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an API is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an API or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other to understand API even better
let's take an example for example you
are booking a flight for that you will
begin with search and flights online
concerning your destination departure
return dates and many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airlines website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those States and what
the cost might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you are doing that
with the help of an API to simplify it
even more it can be said that whenever
we use an application on our mobile
phone the application connects to the
internet and sends data to the server
the server then retrieves the data in
the preset performs necessary actions
and sends it back to our phone the
application then interprets the data and
presents the information we wanted in a
readable way
this is what an API is so that means
each time we use an application like
Facebook send an instant image check
whether on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an API now when we have a good
idea about what an API is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the Hands-On demo that is why we use
jmeter for API testing Apache G meter is
an open source software and it is used
to simulate lots of various scenarios
and output performance data in several
ways including CSP and XML files and
graphs
we know that the Apache jmeter is 100
pure Java application so it is available
on every OS that supports Java 6 or
later
some of these specific reasons what
makes J meter a perfect fit for API
testing are
jmeta enables fast API testing it
performs quick scope tests and enables
load and stress testing then as we know
it is an open source tool and supports
load testing and stress testing it has a
lot of plugins and extensions jmeter can
be used across several platforms and can
use various programming languages now we
know about API Basics and why we use
jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see the process
of API testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
Apache jmeta website and download the
file to know the entire downloading
process and installing jmeter you can
check our jmeta download and
installation video in our jmeter
playlist
moving on I have my geometer installed I
will go to the Apache jmeter folder go
into the bin folder and open the batch
file
this might take a while and then the
geometer window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of that element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the scene
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first J meter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then select group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period and
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user hits third there is a
loop count where you can choose how many
times the test will run for the number
of users you can also choose the test to
run in finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
API for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is r e q r e s dot n or
requestresponse Dot N
we will create and run get post put and
delete rest API request in jmeter in the
demo here in this link we have all get
post put delete apis
so we shall choose the first link here
list users
here we have the link request open this
link in the new tab
then we have got the URL for this API
copy this URL and go to the jmeter
window
then in the jmeter window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
HTTP request here you will have to give
the address to some home pages or
websites
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
so here we shall paste the get API
request URL
in the protocol box we shall put the
https if in the URL the protocol would
have been HTTP then we would have left
this box empty
in the URL we shall put the URL link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here and that anything after the URL
would be put in the path so we shall
remove the path from the URL and put it
in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get API we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value as 2.
in this HTTP request drop down we can
see all the different types of HTTP
requests that jmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get API and also let's name
this HTTP request as get API
now when our HTTP request is ready we
will perform the test on it to determine
what the results of the test will be we
need to add some more test elements we
shall again right click on the thread
group go to The Listener options then in
the Box we can check the different types
of reports that jmeter provides us for
now we shall select two of these let's
choose view results tree and the view
results in the table
now save the test I will save the test
with the name API testing
finally let's run it for running the
test there are three simple ways first
you can simply click the green button on
the Run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the Third Way is you can right click
on the first jmeter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test let's go to
the view results stream here we can see
the green status that shows the test was
successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there is just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing we shall go to the thread
group and change the number of threads
to be 10 and run the test again after
running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and same happens in the
case of view results in table now in the
view results tree we can click on a
request and see different information
here we can see the sample start load
time latency error Etc
same in the view results and table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format you can also see the
response data here this is the same data
as it was there when we copied the URL
from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the requests that was placed
now we are done with the get API request
let's add the second request that is the
post request again add a HTTP request by
going to the sampler in the thread group
then come back to the browser window and
click on the post API option
then open the request URL in the new
window
then go to this window copy the URL and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this HTTP request as
post API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box
address in the server or IP address box
and path in the path box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option
and we shall have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
you can check some advanced settings
also in case you need them for now since
this is just a demo we shall keep it
really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test run in a required number of times
that is 20 times again I can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors Etc
now let's move on to our third API
request that is the put request go back
to the browser and click on put request
open the request in the new tab
copy the URL and come back to the jmeter
window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
put API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box
again let's put HTTP in the protocol box
address the server or IP address box and
path in the path box
and in the HTTP request drop down select
the put option this time
here also we shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here we
shall go to our two listeners and clear
the previous output make the thread
count to be 1 and then we shall save the
test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one here by
clicking on the API request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format let's make
the thread count to be 10 and again see
what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test running a required number of times
and here I can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last API request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
URL and come back to the jmeter window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
delete API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box address in the server
or IP address box and path in the path
box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the delete option this time here
there is nothing to be added in the
parameter section so let's go to the two
listeners and clear what all is there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time we can see the
test running n number of times
we can see the information of any API
request by just clicking on it let's get
started with what is script recording
record testing in jmeter helps testers
to record and run their activity against
test targets it is a type of automated
testing but for multiple users the test
script is designed to record such
scenarios the proxy server allows J
meter to watch and record user activity
while browsing web applications with a
normal web browser when we talk about
proxy it is a component that is present
between you and the remote server let us
say that you want to record web browser
interactions when jmrker starts acting
like a proxy this is when jmeter's
script recording is used script
recording is one of the advanced and
impressive ways to figure out and
eliminate the complexity of browser
interactions and software testing now
when we know what script recording is
and how it is relevant let's look into
how to do it in jmeter but before that
let's check the prerequisites of script
recording in J Meetup there are three
major prerequisites first is having J
meter installed in your system the
second requirement is having Java
installed in your system the third and
final requirement is having Mozilla
Firefox in your system now let us have a
look at the Hands-On demo of how to
perform script recording in jmetup so
the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder we
will go into bin folder and then select
the jmeter.bat folder let us double
click on that this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen the home window is divided
into two sections on the left side all
the test plan elements are added and on
the right side all the configurations of
the elements are added as we are on the
test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and and everything will be
stored here now the first step is to add
thread group so for that right click on
the thread group select add and from add
go to threads or users and in that
select thread group here the thread
group refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states the time gap between
the user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test end
time the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
HTTP request option here there is a
server name or IP Box we have to give
this server name or IP in that let us
pick a website and place the link in the
Box we shall use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
in the server name box keep in mind that
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols that will come
in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box we will
leave a forward slash there since we
have to access the root page now the
next step is to add the HTTP test script
recorder for that right click on the
test plan then go to non-test elements
and select the HTTP test script recorder
option the window on the screen shows
several options here we can see the
start option to begin the test then
there is a box that has the port number
you can make this number whatever you
like I'll put this number as one two
three four for now then let's go back to
the simply learns website and go go to
the resources page then come back to the
jmeters window and rename the recording
controller as resources now let us add
another recording controller so that
jmeter works like a proxy with the help
of https test strip recorder then again
go back to the resources page that we
just opened and scroll down a little bit
here we can see several Technologies and
several other links in those links you
can select any one of the links I will
select digital marketing here then go
back to the jmeter window and rename the
recording controller as digital
marketing then finally let's add a
recording controller for the home page
and rename it as simply learns home page
so now we can see that we have a thread
group here then there is a HTTP request
where we have simply learned website in
the server name then there are three
recording controllers one for the
resources the second for digital
marketing and a third one for home page
and last we have a HTTP test script
recorder here I will rearrange the
recording controllers in sequence
putting the simply launch home page
controller on the top and then placing
the resources finally digital marketing
recording controller now let us open
Mozilla Firefox in our system go to the
general option here and scroll down to
the network settings in the network
settings option select settings in the
window that appears select the manual
proxy configuration here we shall put
the port number for now I will put the
port number as one two three four in
this box
here in the HTTP proxy we have localhost
and we have selected to use this proxy
for FTP and https and then click on ok
now go back to the Apache jmeter folder
and now we shall use this Apache jmeter
temporary root CA file which is a
security certificate file so coming back
to the Mozilla Firefox window go to the
options Tab and in this tab I will type
certificates and here we shall select
view certificates in the window that
opens let us import the security
certificate from jmeta folder here we
shall select these two boxes so that the
proxy server can access the website that
we shall enter here in the browser and
then select OK coming back to the gym
meter window let us add some listeners
to get the results listeners are
something that are used to provide the
outputs of a test there are different
types of listeners present in jmeter and
many may be added using plugins for
adding listeners right click on HTTP
test script recorder for adding
listeners right click on the HTTP test
script recorder then go to add option
and then go to listeners option and then
add view results tree now let us add one
more listener in the same way we shall
add view results entry now in the HTTP
test script recorder in the Target
controller option save the target
controller here in the drop down select
the simply learn home page option as we
will begin the script recording for the
home page finally let's start the test
by clicking here click on ok now go back
to the Mozilla browser and here let us
open the simply learns home page now
come back to the jmeter window go to the
home page recording controller you can
see the home page controller has started
as you can see the home page controller
has started recording the scripts that
are being performed these are the tasks
that are performed on the client side to
the server side now we can check both
the listeners that we have put to see
what all functions are working fine and
what all are not all the tasks from the
time that we have entered to
simplylearn.com in our browser are
recorded in this home page controller to
take the test further go to the test
script recorder and stop the test now
here in the Target controller select the
second controller that is the resources
controller now start the test again
select ok go to Simply learns website
select resources after opening the
resources link go back to the geometer
window and now in the resources
controller you can see what all events
are recorded from the client side to the
server side once we click on the
resources link now again in the tool
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test tip recorder and stop
the test now here in the Target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
Target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the Mozilla Firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client side to the server side once we
click on that link I guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the toll
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is RJ meter that
is why it was able to record all the
steps that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeta script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings and that's how it is done
with that we have come to end of the
session on devops testing tutorial
should you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in the session
or should you feel that you need the
resources used in the session like the
PPT code demonstration or projects then
feel free to let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be more than happy to resolve all
your queries at the earliest until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here